[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
consacré aux jeux olympiques puisque
vous le savez les jeux olympiques ont
été attribués à paris mais aussi à la
seine-saint-denis mais aussi aux divines
et notamment à saint quentin en yvelines
où se dérouleront pas mal d'épreuves
une victoire qui a été plutôt bien
accueillies comme si la france renoué
avec un optimiste un optimisme qui n'a
pas toujours été son fort alors s'agit
plus de savoir s'il faut faire ou pas
faire les jeux olympiques ça c'est fait
ils vont ils auront lieu en 2024
mais il s'agit de savoir comment les
réussit un peut-être ce qu'ils peuvent
nous apporter pour en parler sylvie
léonard
bonjour je vous avais notant longtemps
occupé du tourisme dans les yvelines
aujourd'hui vous êtes experte tollé
international donc vous allez nous dire
ce que l'on peut attendre peut-être deux
des événements comme ceux-là au niveau
du tourisme jean-pierre sevestre vous
êtes le maire de quoi dire vous êtes de
vice-président de 50 ans on y dîne
chargé des sports donc voilà c'est à
vous qu'il faut s'adresser poliana rni
tad bonjour vous êtes le directeur du
golf national de plus le plus
francophile et désormais tenir c'est sa
maîtresse du golfeur
vous aviez déjà atteint le summum de
votre carrière en sachant que ryder cup
prochaine et là un autre sommet m'arrive
avec des jeux olympiques est-ce que vous
durera jusqu'en 2024
après j'espère on espère tous oui
j'essaie de me garder en forme
d'escargot et jocelyn joly éditait jeu à
bordeaux alors vous êtes tout à fait
favorable mais vous aviez publié dans
votre maison d'édition deux ou trois
livres qui était pas tellement favorable
sport j'adore le sport pour faire
j'ai quelques réserves sur le lantus
dias mais la veille un grand
enthousiasme cadré attitude on a
l'impression d'être dans le pays des
bisounours quoi maintenant tout va bien
tout est bonne a tout oublié tout est
extraordinaire on va parler je décidais
de votre dernier un publication du passé
faisons table rase de ma luc à gagner
absolument
malika gagne enfin c'est un polar un
très bon polar historique qui se passe
entre maintenant et les années les
années de plomb derrière le en union
soviétique et le rideau de fer donc
l'histoire nous emmène de de strasbourg
à riga et maintenant et il ya 45 ans
voilà tout à fait fabriquer les vieux
c'est quand même bien cotés en revanche
alors avec vous évidemment là le fait
que les jeux olympiques soit athée voué
à paris c'était un faux suspens à tout
le monde le savait mais c'est quand même
c'était officiellement officiel
voilà sept lycées les ficelles et c'est
quand même une victoire et c'est une
victoire c'est une victoire d'un projet
d'un projet important d'un projet
d'un projet qui a va mettre paris au
coeur au coeur de l'olympisme avec ses
valeurs les valeurs de respect ses
valeurs d'excellence et ses grandes
valeurs olympiques donc c'est quelque
chose de très important un projet qui a
été porté par énormément de partenaires
que ce soit du monde économique que ce
soient des partenaires des collectivités
publiques des ong et bien sûr le monde
politique également
et puis les sportifs les sportifs ont
porté ce projet d'une façon remarquable
et puis tony estanguet notamment tony
sont nés notamment tony estanguet dont
la loi c'est c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire le samedi
avant-hier nous avions tony estanguet
effectivement en ligne et c'était
extraordinaire de fêter une liesse
extraordinaire d'avoir ce projet ya eu
une défaite au vélodrome oui je vous
propose on y était donc je propose de
regarder ce qui se passait quand les
jeux olympiques d'été attribués et c'est
donc au vélodrome de saint quentin
une très belle journée la fièvre
olympique s'est propagée dans le
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ce mercredi 13 septembre plus de 500
supporters tricolores sont venus
assister en direct à l'annoncé du cio
via des écrans géants installés pour
l'occasion
bah oui c'est important ça faisait
longtemps que paris attend les jo donc
je pense que c'est important de célébrer
tous ensemble cet événement aujourd'hui
être présent
pour cette première échéance je dirais
de confirmation de gillot oui c'est
important on est acteur tous autant
qu'on est à chaque niveau donc oui pour
faire entendre ses fans jusqu'à
l'annoncé officielle des animations
sportives étaient organisées sur place
le rider de l'équipe de france jérémy
rencurel qualifiés pour les derniers
jeux olympiques à rio l'été dernier en a
profité pour faire des démonstrations
avec des enfants devant le public
c'est important parce que ça ça pousse
il a fait découvrir aussi le baby c'est
pas un sport très médiatisée notamment
la piste peut-être un peu plus et du
coup bah ça fait connaître notre sport
après de longues minutes d'attentes le
verdict tombe enfin paris officiellement
désignée ville hôte pour les jeux
olympiques de 2024 par le film est une
réaction extraordinaire une réaction de
joie une réaction de joie
les jeux olympiques sont à paris en 2024
c'est officiellement officiel maintenant
et là c'est vraiment une explosion de
joie on a senti lors de l' annonce est
maintenant l aventure commence une
aventure commence est une aventure
historique et ça va être passionnant de
vivre cette période
les supporters présents vélodrome
national espère maintenant vibrer dans
un peu moins de 7 ans avec des médailles
d'or françaises
voilà la nouvelle c'est que jean pierre
serre est réparé tout le plateau et dans
les cités mais c'est vrai voilà vous
étiez vous n'étiez pas en charge des
sports quand contre la candidature de
paris m'a été refusé non effectivement
ces faits 2005 et je n'étais pas en
charge des sports et manière n'était
pendant l'agglomération de saleilles
divine effectivement c'est une période
plus ancienne plus ancienne mais vous
vous souvenez de la déception je me
souviens de la déception je me souviens
de la déception parce que je suis un
ancien sportif est donc ce sont des
périodes qui sont remplis de joie et de
liesse comme nous vivons actuellement
mais ce sont des périodes de déception
le comme 2005 et fait naïvement et 2005
ne nous étions pas même la france
s'était investi tout de même dans ceux
dans ce projet d'une façon remarquable
et nous avons la construction du
vélodrome national à saint quentin qui
est une conséquence aussi de cette
candidature aux jeux olympiques de 2012
à londres
alors c'est un des aspects pardon en
2005 y avait aussi d'autres candidats
alors que là c'est une compétition d'une
compétition qu'on a gagné tout seul il
faut un candidat s'était retirée assez
c'est assez rare oui parce que nous
sommes étaient très bonne aussi vous
parce que nous avons travaillé à ce
qu'il se retire aussi proche de la télé
dit non on a probablement appris de
l'échec de 2005
on entendait encore des archives de
bertrand de la noue et expliquer comment
tony blair sept s'étaient mobilisés de
même il est allé voir les membres du
comité du jeux olympiques et peut-être
qu'on a appris justement de cons c'est
peut-être mieux proposer une candidature
qu'on ne le faisaient il ya quelques
années dans des défaites
justement
vous ne disiez d'ailleurs le vélodrome
par exemple a été construit pour les
jeux olympiques de 2005 l'un des réseaux
et 2012 de 2009 art 2000 a été mise en
2014 c'est quasiment l'un des aspects
justement qui fait débat c'est le coût
des jeux olympiques ou parle de 6
milliards c'est vrai que la plupart des
dessus ce qui doit être construit pour
pour les jeux olympiques l'a déjà été
c'est à dire que donc le coût de
construction ne sera pas moindre voilà
le coût de construction somme sera
moindre et il est dans ce projet qui a
été présenté des utilisations qui seront
conservés et je pense notamment au
village olympique donc ce sont des
constructions qui permettront ensuite
d'avoir des logements supplémentaires
dans ce dans cette partie nord-est de
paris et de d'avoir une ça permet de de
faire grandir grandir la région et faire
grandir plus particulièrement
effectivement cela seine-saint-denis et
cette région là pas le dire d'ailleurs
maintiennent le le fait par c'est
peut-être deux choses différentes enfin
le fait que la ryder cup et été attribué
au gloss nationale ça donnait quand même
une dimension à ce territoire qu'elle
n'avait pas jusque là et ça peut-être
joué aussi dans cette candidature de
paris
je pense aux juges dont le président de
la fédération s'est engagé fédération de
golf s'est engagée immédiatement avec
pareille 2024 déjà pour mettre à
disposition le golfe pour les jo de 2024
nous on est passé comme vous savez un
2015 2016 par 7 millions presque 8
millions de travaux sur le golf national
en préparation en vue de la ryder cup
l'année prochaine ce sont des travaux
qui vont amortir sur 15 20 ans donc on
sera tous jeunes tout beau tout neuf
pour les jo il y aura pas
d'investissements nécessaires pour le
golf ont tout pour le tout en tout cas
grâce à vous nous disiez tour est un peu
de com sa série il ya tout le côté
extrêmement positif
effectivement comme vous le disait très
justement tous les deux la ryder cup la
capacité des françaises à organiser les
grands événements que soi même et en 98
et la coupe du monde l'euro il ya pas
très longtemps leurs hôtes football fan
on sait faire hélas il faut quand même
parler sécurité et de terrorisme etc
c'était déjà le cas à l'euro de football
s'est remarquablement bien passé on sait
hélas que toute façon ça on pas on
échappera pas c'est même une réponse
menace enfin le fait d'avoir accordé les
jeux olympiques à paris c'est aussi une
réponse aux attaques terroristes
réponse donc ça je pense que c'est
vraiment un point positif l'autre point
que ton extrêmement positif c'est que
j'ai un petit peu comme il ya des années
ça va un peu émergé jean claude killy et
là j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une
personnalité extraordinaire qui a qui
apparaît qui est distancée estanguet
ceux qui paient un charisme
extraordinaire il allait absolument
épatant ou au dessus des dd des clivages
politiques etc en avant l'aube ce type
va porter sur lui tout seul
les jeux olympiques enfin en tout cas
c'est un ambassadeur merveilleux et est
peut-être un patron des jeux qui est qui
était patent après il ya quand même un
côté assez terrorisant dire que cet
unanimisme et autour de ces jeux et
surtout cette capacité que visiblement
tout le monde a à évacuer tout ce qui
pourrait ne pas marcher ou tous les
inconvénients des jeux serco vous en
parlait il ya deux minutes 6 milliards
on sait très bien que ça va pas être
similaire mais ça va alors généralement
c'est normalement c'est 30 40 % et ceux
ci s'étaient 289% qu'est ce qui était
prévu c'est toujours un peu plus mais
surtout c'est toujours tous un peu plus
sur les dépenses et c'est toujours un
peu moins pour les emplois en fait c'est
toujours le savannah temps je vois deux
semaines 250 mille emplois créés à peu
près ça va toujours ça va aussi est un
peu pareil on va dire madame vous en
parler mais le monde entier va venir
chez nous au quai les touristes vont
venir mais les touristes qui viennent
pour les jo ils viendront pas le mois
d'avant et viendront pas le mois d'après
donc ok ça fait venir du monde mais mais
c'est pas faux ce n'est pas les mêmes
beaucoup
et puis enfin et un truc qui moi
m'inquiète c'est que tout le monde parle
d'écologie que c'était assez merveilleux
mais enfin bon je veux dire on va quand
même massacrés probablement 1,2 hectare
et demi de deux terrains à paris d'un
jardin magnifique pour construire un
autre stade il est peut-être un autre
endroit pour le faire peut pas dire qu à
paris quand même ces villes en bouteille
est pollué salle etc
on avait besoin de massacrer deux
hectares et demi de de verdure drôle
alors je parle même pas de roland garros
et les serres d'auteuil qu'on a passé la
laine la maire de paris qui n'a que que
le l'écologie à la bouche quand il
s'agit de de polluer de bloquer la ville
la serres d'auteuil c'est pas grave
le deux hectares et demi de terre en
moins c'est pas grave non plus voilà je
suis un peu étonné par tous mais la
maire de paris dit que si j'ai bien lu
l'attend une réduction de 55 profonde
empreinte carbone en baisse par rapport
aux jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
londres 2012 est sûr que tout le monde
sera englué moteur à l'arrêt dans sa
voiture par des encombrements monstrueux
je dire oui la faute de combattants
paris ne sera plus pollués alors vous
vous trouvez qu'on a un peu trop comme
ça optimiste nous avons des raisons de
la non la raison la raison de l'être
tout à fait non il faut écouter ce qu'il
faut moduler la c'est une caricature
tout de même de monsieur c'est une
caricature de bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
à partir de mango nous apportons
énormément de trafic énormément de
personnes qui vont venir pour les
épreuves
je pense qu'effectivement il ya une des
conséquences des conséquences
écologiques bien sûr mais je pense qu'on
s'en remet rapidement parce que ce sont
des projets tout de même qu'ils sont
maîtrisés donc on s'en remet facilement
et je vais parler de la colline
d'elancourt par exemple pour revenir sur
le plan local
eh bien nous aurons un aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt qui va nous
permettre d'avoir est probablement une
un parcours vtt qui sera pérenne ensuite
et c'est l'occasion
effectivement c'est une colline qui
n'est pas aménagé depuis de nombreuses
années et qui va permettre un
aménagement à l'occasion ces jeux
olympiques et je pense que c'est
c'est un exemple local mais c'est un
exemple intéressant et puis il ya notre
exemple c'est par exemple les visites
techniques qu'on a eu pour être un site
olympique en a été on a eu une visite
particulier pour le développement
durable pour être sûr que on n'allait
pas faire n'importe quoi avec des
spectateurs qui peuvent marcher un peu
partout marché sur un grenouille j'en
sais rien voilà on a été contrôlé et on
a dû faire une offre adaptée pour
justement ces soucis de développement
durable et ça c'est pour le national
committee comme on dit ça comme il ya le
dire et nous on est suivi par un contrat
avec la fédération française de golf le
golf national en vue de la ryder et djo
par le muséum d'histoire naturelle pour
remettre en état tout ce qu'on peut
détruire par ces événements là il ya des
groupes on va dire de golf pour
l'utilisation des pesticides etc qui
étaient quand même très répandue
quelques années 00 fiton il valait en
vain
droit comme ça avec lui faut qu'on
trouve des solutions plus et en les uns
au gala national donc ça c'est ça c'est
déjà bien par amour on peut dire je
crois que c'est une idée qui dit ça mais
est-ce que les olympiques sont un
formidable accélérateur de projets je
pense je pense mais je pense est un
formidable accélérateur c'est un élan
que qui va être donnée au pays entier
c'est un élan magnifique mais bien sûr
il faut se mettre au travail dès
maintenant mais c'est un élan magnifique
un élan également pour notre jeunesse
pour la génération actuelle qui va dans
en 2024 qui aura avant-hier nous étions
au vélodrome avec 800 enfants pendant
une bonne partie de la journée mais il y
avait il une générosité dans cette
génération qui voit les jeux olympiques
y arriver maintenant à paris en france
dans sept ans mais qui qui ont une
volonté d'arriver mais c'est
extraordinaire et je pense qu'en voyant
ses élèves ces lycéens
ces collégiens pardon nous avions envie
avec eux d'y aller leur père ce héros là
je suis peut-être un petit peu cher
l'enthousiasmé a levé
c'est un mot de jours chaque puits après
sylvie léonard on va parler de tourisme
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
monsieur mais il en va des jeux
olympiques je pense comme de l'europe
moi je dis personnel je suis tout à fait
pour l'europe ce qui ne m'empêche pas de
la critique et de dire que tout ne va
pas bien en europe qu il faut faire
attention et les jeux olympiques je suis
à fond pour mais je suis content c'est
cette folie comme c'est à dire tout va
bien tout est merveilleux et on ne voit
pas le côté quelquefois dangereux et
écologiquement quelquefois bizarre en
sachant que moi je suis je suis ravi
qu'on construise des millions de deux
chambres et de lits pour qu'on gardera
pour les étudiants et pour je ne sais
pas qui après je me dis c'est quand même
un peu dommage parce que si on a tout
cet argent si la mairie de paris est
tout à fait capable de tout d'un coup de
trouver de l'argent pour construire des
ddd logements pour les étudiants
pourquoi attentons 2024 est-ce qu'on
pourrait pas démarrer les logements
maintenant loger des étudiants et
déloger les étudiants pour le village
olympique
on attend toujours il s'était passé la
même chose avec les migrants tout d'un
coup à hidalgo avait dit mais j'ai
cinquante mille places pour loger les
migrants ben je veux dire je pense que
tous les sdf et tous mes balles logées
avait dû dire la ceinture yeux tout d'un
coup on trouve 50000 places
et là c'est un peu pareil où on va
trouver de l'argent à autrui des places
pour des logements alors n'attendons pas
de 1024 si l'argent est là feu faisons
faisons un peu plus vite quand il a una
la chose de totalement différente
vendredi c'est deux choses totalement
différentes à vous d'essayer de prouver
que les jeux olympiques ne servent à
rien
c'est il y as her comme j'ai précisé il
ya l'élan derrière le populaire l'élan
de la nation c'est extraordinaire c'est
extraordinaire c'est par là des
logements savary zad et si on en croit
d'ailleurs cias mme de sportifs non mais
si on ne prend d'ailleurs les études
d'opinion le blu pillon et très
favorable à l'organisation de deux de
ses jeux si tu es là ou alors c'est un
expert de tourisme qu'elles ne causent
pas là évidemment déjà est-ce que je
vais revenir un petit peu avant les jeux
la ryder cup est ce que déjà une
influence sur le tourisme dans ce
territoire versailles sans aura une bien
sûr oui au niveau de la fréquentation au
moment de la ryder cup mais c'est
toujours pareil avec tous les événements
quels qu'ils soient il ya
un développement de la fréquentation au
moment de l'événement
sauf que la clientèle habituelle ne
vient plus si vous voulez sahraouis qui
se fait c'est plutôt des étrangers
l'institut elle se dit bien moi à ce
moment là je vais pas venir je dois
calmont séjour et ça se fera de la même
façon aux jeux olympiques en 2010 de la
même façon que des gens qui habitent pas
rire en vacances probable en vous
exactement et haineux n'iront pas à
paris alors qu'ils avaient programmé
peut-être d'y aller s'il n'y avait pas
eu les jeux olympiques
donc effectivement c'est tous les
événements sportifs ou grands événements
quels qu'ils soient donne un coup de
projecteur sur la destination ça passe
sur toutes les télés on a le paris nice
par exemple dans les yvelines
donc ça passe partout sur toutes les
télés ça donne envie de venir
ça crée un engouement pour la
destination mais cet engouement
il est souvent que pour moi après et
après après la manifestation pour le
touriste lambda qui n'est pas forcément
un sportif qui a pas forcément envie de
venir sur la manifestation
donc globalement si on regarde les
retombées touristiques ce sera plutôt
après qu'après clairement que pendant
qu'on va avoir parlé
de tous les sites de paris me d'amande
la seine saint denis qui est importante
les yvelines qui sont importants et
peut-être que les gens voyageront
horrifique pas exempt de parler ils vont
vouloir venir voir pendant évidemment il
ya toujours le même les sportifs qui ont
envie de voir parce que c'est une
manifestation mondiale
on a envie de venir mais il y en a qui
se disent banon pour visiter
tranquillement le patrimoine francilien
moi je viendrai plus tard et ça s'est
passé de cette façon en 1998 un peu loin
maintenant mais pour la coupe du monde
de football et c'était ça les
fréquentations elles ont été très très
bon évidemment mais on a vu l'année
d'après une formidable augmentation des
fréquentations partout sur le territoire
et dans les yvelines
ça n'a pas ça n'a pas échappé à la règle
donc pour le golf national sa veux dire
contre 2018 et 2022 quatre volets plein
ce qu'on dit l'un c'est clair que l'on
attendait des retombées force après mais
j'ai quand même un message d'espoir et
et est positif c'est que si on prend par
rapport à 2014 à 2017 nous sommes en x
10 sur le tour opérateur dans les 10 x
10 alors ça veut pas dire qu'on faisait
un pour dix aujourd'hui mais on est très
content de ce qui se passe avant
l'événement mais il ya quelque chose de
particulier chez le golfeur qui explique
ça c'est pas nécessairement pour tous
l'espoir et c'est que quand un golf
devient lieu de majeur ou un golf de
lieux
ryder cup il rentre sur ce qu'on appelle
le bucket list d'un joueur de golf c'est
la liste de golf qui doit faire avant de
mourir
non mais c'est vrai la fin de sa vie
qu'ils gelaient et donc c'est
particulier c'est que en un un flux de
touristes étrangères 50% ensemble des
anglais est à peu près 30% c'est des
scandinaves des néerlandais
le reste des américains des chinois
actuellement ça ça va se développer à
l'avenir après l'événement justement on
va venir de plus loin après les plus
plein entre les deux événements parce
que les gens ils jouent debout avant la
ryder cup que cela arrivait il savoir et
je vais vous donner un autre exemple en
a fait plus de 2000 nuitées de plus
cette année dans divers hôtels notamment
l'hôtel sur site mais aussi dans
d'autres hôtels 2000 nuitées de plus
cette année que nous avons fournis ne
pas nous amène aux tour opérateurs mais
gérer girafe et boîtes aux lettres pour
eux donc on peut savoir ça sur le plan
local
deux minutes et c'est pour quand ils
repassent de transport c'est beaucoup de
taxi s'est beaucoup de repas c'est vrai
que c'est une situation un des rares
sports où les gens peuvent se mesurer au
même parfois j'étais on peut pas aller
jouer au parc des princes au foot de ce
que je fous ton papa des joueurs à
roland garros si on joue au tennis mais
on peut aller jouer au golf
non mais c'est rare yaya le vélodrome il
ya lui et devait le groupe c dans
l'inclusion du cycliste et gray
également et qui accueille même des
soirées d'exception agonise
à mon avis les entreprises vont vouloir
davantage envie d'aller d'aller
privatiser le vélo 2
photo véritable vecteur de mouvement et
de tourisme tandis qu effectivement on
va tennisman ne paraît pas les hommes
voilà c'est produit participants
formidable vecteur de création de
richesse pour le pays
les aimer open de france chaque année va
aussi maintenir la pression pour la
ryder cup
et puis il ya la boîte à l'open de
france jeux olympiques c'est encore plus
important on va y venir peut-être mais
ça nous met dans une place unique sur
cette planète terre il ya aucun au golf
dans le monde qui a accueilli une ryder
cup et des jeux dont nelly seul en est
les seuls ayant sera seul je pense pour
de nombreuses années
aller en angleterre il y avait les
nouvelles golf peut-être pas encore
comme je t'aime comme discipline
olympique lui ce qui explique que parce
que sinon ça aurait été un véritable
arrêt c'est incroyable très bonne
nouvelle pour pour la région là c'est
incroyable existants est-ce que vous
avez déjà eu des contacts avec les
entreprises avec les oui bien sûr il ya
déjà d une sensibilisation des
entreprises
du territoire de saint quentin sur les
douze communes aux jeux olympiques ce
certaines entreprises et notamment les
entreprises importantes du territoire
ont déjà participé au projet déjà
participé à différentes
nous avons soutenu également avec les
entreprises la candidature 2024 jeux
olympiques
et alors on parler d'emploi de création
un poids ont dit à peu près l'aube
allemand de 50 villes à 300000 emplois
fin mai jeudi après les chiffres je dois
vous dire non
c'est ce qu'estiment les économistes
enfin bon on est passionné on sait quels
sont les emplois par exemple qui sur ce
territoire et donc qui pourraient être
créés par le jeux olympiques
je pense que les emplois peuvent être
créés bon pendant les jeux olympiques
pendant les jeux olympiques
effectivement mais je pense qu'il y a
y'a quoi y'a de la sécurité est la
sécurité qui va être créée effectivement
mais il ya également des infrastructures
qui devraient être créés et je pense
notamment la ligne 18
la ligne 18 du grand paris et gallas
visite du grand paris doit qui doit
arriver donc
sur saint quentin est et qu'il faut
absolument bien sûr réalisé avant les
jeux olympiques pour les jeux olympiques
et je pense que c'est une des raisons
qui doit aboutir à la réalisation de
cette réalité il fait quoi
c'est entre saclay et puis orly et saint
quentin est guyancourt et ensuite pour
rejoindre versailles pour la ryder cup
des yeah yeah yeahs
comment ça se passe et les transports et
très bien oui oui oui il ya un plan de
transport qui a été pensé aux millions
de la fédération les les promoteurs
détenteurs de droits qui est ryder cup
europe et puis avec les collectivités
locales
il ya un grand travail qui a été fait
qui est toujours en cours mais qui est
finalisé donc on va avoir est et ouest
transports publics par les rer e gare de
massy saint quentin et versailles
parking à satory pour ceux qui
souhaitent avec des navettes jusqu'à
l'ancienne usine de thales par exemple
qui va être gardé pour faire des
terminales terminaux pardon de bus est
il ya la même chose dans un champ qui a
été gentiment loué pour pour deux ans
donc on est en train de langast zone etc
pour pouvoir acheminer les gens le plus
près du parcours mais sans avoir
beaucoup de voitures autour du parcours
d arrêt il autour du seul au parking qui
aura ce sera véritablement pour l'heure
les eaux arctiques joueurs seront en
navette
voilà ah oui oui ils seront bus h 10 et
bouclé les six autres à paris mais c'est
vrai qu'elle assène sony et c'est vrai
qu'il ya les yvelines alors je propose
de regarder quels sont les sites des
yvelines qui sont concernés par ces jeux
un appétit on en reparle après 50 ans ni
winne sera l'honneur pendant les jo de
2024 quatre sites ont été retenus par
les organisateurs français les épreuves
de cyclisme sur piste seront programmés
dans le vélodrome nationale la structure
inaugure en 2014 a déjà accueilli les
championnats du monde en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
bien sûr ça à lèvres
sur sur toutes les interrogations qu'on
pourrait avoir la l'équipement il est là
il a été testé il a accueilli déjà la
plus grandes échéances internationales
avec les championnats du monde donc je
pense que tout ça c'est forcément des
garanties pour le seuil haut à une
centaine de mètres du vélodrome lille de
loisirs de 50 ans livide a été
sélectionné dans le dossier paris 2024
pour accueillir les épreuves masculines
et féminines de bmx une piste modulable
sera construite sur ce terrain vague de
sept hectares
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jouent je te le vélodrome
on est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite
complémentarité entre les épreuves qui
se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et les
épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du cadre
nature qui s'y prête parfaitement la
colline d'elancourt accueillera quant à
elle les épreuves de vtt le projet dans
les cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a été
ressortie pour la candidature de paris
2024 le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir à quelque chose de
très raide
donc oui c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
hanche
enfin le golf national recevrait les
épreuves golfique les joueurs
disputeront les parties sur le parcours
de l'albatros le 18 trous réputé comme
l'un des plus compliqués au monde et est
entièrement rénové entre 2015 et 2016
ce challenge super compétition et dans
l'est
les jo les gones nationale serait le
premier parcours du vol du monde andres
et world title 4 et légion donc assez
commun mais non ça fait pas peur c'est
simplement goodchild est plus à sa
savane d'émotion à la vie dans le reste
des yvelines les épreuves d'équitation
de pentathlon moderne se disputeront à
versailles les courses de cyclisme sur
route devrait quant à elle passer dans
la vallée de chevreuse alors oui il ya
donc trois sports concernés il ya le
vélo là le vélo ça c'est très très
important puisqu'il ya la piste avec le
vélodrome nationale et puis le bmx donc
avec une piste réalisé sur l'île de
loisirs par le cio donc il y à un
financement intégral par le cio ça sur
le dos de 50 ans sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin et ensuite la colline
d'elancourt qu être aménagés pour
accueillir les épreuves de vtt et la
route et la route je pense également
heureuse probablement et puis à une
arrivée sur les champs elysées avaient
peut-être avec peut-être un départ à
versailles également égalé les virages
de dampierre ces temps de l'épreuve
connu par les inconnus par les cyclistes
et lui laisse épreuves d'équitation au
château de versailles à versailles
choisi pour l'équitation le pentathlon
moderne également à versailles
et puis au vélodrome nationale on sait
que je pense sport disciplines
différentes
et puis donc nous accueillerons
également sur leur central du vélodrome
les scream du pentathlon moderne
ah oui voilà ce sont les sports qui
seront accueillis au sein du territoire
et plus le goal versailles
bien sûr bien sûr le mans nous sommes
est et puis je voudrais rajouter
d'ailleurs sur le golf golf national
bien sûr et puis circuit d'albatros qui
est vraiment extraordinaire
vraiment nous l'avons un circuit
parcours extraordinaire un parcours
extraordinaire mais le golf est un
facteur d'aménagement
paysage est extraordinaire je pense que
pour le symbole du développement durable
je pense qu'on peut penser aux boeufs
c'est une discipline qui apporte
effectivement les joueurs dans la nature
qui font 6 7 km pour faire un parcours
donc ces sportifs et en même temps c'est
un aménagement extraordinaire pour une
région et là nous avons effectivement
sur le territoire nous avons deux golf
de 18 trous effectivement observé sur la
base de loisirs sur l'idh loisirs par
contre oui si on prend les écrits il ya
des et sur le territoire et puis nous
avons également le plan d'eau sur cette
île de loi qui est aussi le plus grand
plan d'eau d'ile-de-france donc nous
avons un territoire qui est là pour
accueillir le sport c'est un stade à
ciel ouvert je dirais seulement voilà
alors ça pas toujours été le cas pour le
golf à ce que nous parfois dans les
années 80 des golfs qui se construisait
pour qu'on puisse mettre des petites
amies mais de l'immobilier dessus mais
là ça n'est pas avec la prise de
conscience du développement durable et
de l'écologie je pense que le golf s'est
adapté une façon extraordinaire et
notamment le golf national puisque vous
êtes expert international c'est quoi une
image quand on dit par exemple la ryder
cup où les jeux olympiques connie paris
c'est pour les gens c'est quoi paris
versailles alors ça dépend dans quel
pays on les met à l'international c'est
paris versailles c'est pour les
européens plus à l'est à l'international
on pense que faire ça il ya dans paris
april train on a pris le train on est
arrivé à versailles mais on ne sait pas
qu'on est plus dans paris comme nounou
d'une tonne plus loin mais
non mais je dire de résister pour les
gens sérieux non mais à l'international
c'est paris paris paris voilà après
qu'on soit à versailles à saint quentin
on croit qu'on est dans paris d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs la région se bat pour faire
connaître les sites hors paris enfin
quand on travaille à la région pour
développer le tourisme
le mot île de france par exemple
personne sait ce que c'est à
l'international vous imaginez bien pour
un étrange île de france c'est ça peut
encore de france et non pas du tout pas
du tout donc c est ce mieux c'est le
grand paris est ce que ça veut dire à
temps plein ce n est pas ce que ça veut
dire que au fond la région c'est fini ça
va être le grand paris à l'heure où
paris n'a pas quand même encore absorber
toutes là toute la grande banlieue quand
même encore un nom nous en sommes encore
loin mais est-ce qu'il va pas y voir une
sorte de grand paris et puis le reste
ah oui c'est bien ce qui est à craindre
actuelle est traité comme adam dit
effectivement pour un international
paris et versailles
c'est paris mais c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose tout de même pour les
franciliens notamment pas du tout et
pour les habitants de saint quentin les
problèmes de transport sont quand même
aussi très important
donc nous ne sommes pas à paris lorsque
nous sommes à saint-quentin tous les
franciliens la qualité vidéo n'est pas
du tout heureusement grâce à une
association c'est différent mais vous
ressentez aussi sur le sur le golf pour
les pour les sportifs ou pour le sait
paris on est très attachés à notre
territoire
oui c'est bien normal parce qu'on avait
besoin dead et d'amis il ya longtemps et
à 2008 quand la fédération voulait
candidater pour
pour la ryder cup il fallait des moyens
et on les a trouvés très proche de chez
nous donc on essaye de promouvoir le
maximum notre territoire
50 en avertir les yvelines etc mais
effectivement contient en termes de
marketing par exemple c'est vrai qu'on
est obligé de dire on est à paris
on est obligé d irin tour eiffel non ça
c'est pourtant notre image non ça c'est
pour nos présentations en interne on
attend que vous avez eu la chance de
voir le nom mais quand vous parlez avec
les les les grands responsables de golf
et des érables pour la ryder cup 7 paris
non oui clairement
clairement on est obligé de dire paris
on peut pas dire celle de golf national
louise harel aussi on dit c'est dans les
yvelines paris cci s'imagine t elle
c'est pas tout à fait le montant de
présenter au golf national on est obligé
de dire qu'on est à 30 minutes ce
n'était pas alors il ya tous les aspects
on ne peut pas développer donc les
aspects financiers en se disant voilà
espère on espère que les budgets
voilà seront tenues tout à l'argent sale
parler de te dis et ce touriste et la
présence des sportifs dans la
candidature dans et dans la wii dans la
case et des mesures qui étaient portés
et dans le rôle qui ne roule pourtant
qui joue parler de jean claude killy
n'ayez pas de jean claude killy il y
avait aussi des politiques
avec avec lui c'est important de voir
les deux parce que c'est important
d'avoir les polices les sportifs mais là
je pensais que la présentation d'un
projet de jeux olympiques
ce sont les sportifs et les politiques
je pense que et c'est là un peu la
différence entre le la présentation le
projet que qu'ils étaient prêts qui a
été celui de 2005 et celui de 2017
les paul était plus en avant les
politiques étaient plus en avant
ce n'est pas un reproche aux politiques
c'est hélas nous avons trouvé
effectivement à tony estanguet en teddy
riner également ce sont des personnages
qui sont vraiment sportif qui dit des
médaillés olympiques remarquable et donc
ça apporte quelque chose de vraiment
sportif et des et plus
plus concret sur les compétitions plus
concret sur les résultats et les landes
sportif que ça peut apporter
mais disons si ce que le politique est
quand même très important parce que si
on se souvient important tony blair tony
blair
peut-être aussi nommé par dont vous
parlez de deux clis qui est vrai qu'il
ya eu un rôle très important mais en
sous main il y avait michel barnier est
derrière aller voir les met à les
convaincre aussi il ya aussi tout un
travail un peu sous terrain et c'est
bien de mettre les sportifs en première
ligne en avant mais il ya un travail
politique important aussi
et puis aussi mais ça peut peut-être
vous vous faire hurler tous les quatre
mais je pense qu'il ya aussi un aspect
physique et sportif des hommes
politiques c'est à dire que tony blair
qui était quand même assez assez
sportive jeunes et cgra il est important
là on a mon hamac rond qui est quand
même jeunes qui peuvent entrer poteau et
c'est grâce à de l'eau si l'image
sportive du du politique et ce qui est
très important ce qui n'a pas toujours
été le cas et notamment français même
dans l'oubli on a quand même parcelle
politique quelquefois un peu plus âgé
c'est une image dynamique puisque deux
parties égales à riga on a vu à craquer
qui ne toujours prêt à enfiler une tenue
de sport ou sous marinier qui comprend
trois ans qui mouillent ça j'avais doit
en théorie qui jouent au foot ça c'est
important mais effectivement ce mixte
politique résulte y fait et c'est bien
ce que là on sent qu'il ya une osmose
que tout à fait sympathique break
je dirais que la présence de d'emmanuel
macron a été surtout de même la fin du
projet c'était une image de jeunesse on
passe un peu ceux ci danse françois
hollande de ses communiqués qui a initié
le projet à l'époque anne hidalgo
étaient d'ailleurs tout à fait opposé
lui dira c'est pour le président de
décider à nicolas sarkozy et à emmanuel
macron et a passé sous silence a initié
cette démarche qu'elle ait pas double
votre rôle en tant que responsable des
sports sur les jeux sur les jeux
olympiques maintenant effectivement nous
devons dans l'est la période de sept ans
c'est long plus le même
oui et donc mais nous avons sur le je
parle du territoire nous aurons un livre
sur le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines nous avons 400 associations
sportives et donc il est temps je pense
maintenant de ddc associations sportives
nous avons des champions des sportifs de
haut niveau également sur sur le
territoire et il nous faut maintenant
avec cet élan des jeux olympiques
permettre à ces sportifs d'aller vers
les jeux olympiques et il nous faut à
l'aide de la population également il
faut sensibiliser la population à l'aide
des différents évènements qui vont se
dérouler tout au long des années
de 2018 2 mai fin 2017 jusqu'en 2023
il nous faut sensibiliser la population
aux à ces jeux olympiques par de la
communication sur chaque événement et
nous avons énormément d'événements sur
saint quentin en yvelines il y a
énormément d'équipements sportifs
également nous sommes très bien équipée
en sportivement donc il nous faut
appuyer la motivation des sportifs à
appuyer et aider les associations
nous avons déjà 400 à 500 à 400
associations savent ou du sport enfin
s'occupe du sport sur 59 énorme
si nous prenons les associations
culturelles également nous arrivons à
plus de 2000 d'associations sur le
méritoire et donc c'est c'est un élément
important je pense le bénévolat les
associations il faut aider aider les
sportifs et je pense également
est ce que nous avons creed et risée
dans les attributions de subventions aux
associations
c'est aider les associations qui
également aide les sports les
handisports le parallèle paralympiques
de permettre également d'intégrer dans
les associations ces personnes qui ont
des difficultés qui peuvent par dick est
un sport est arrivé à des niveaux et
nous avons rencontré j'ai encore des
jeunes et avant-hier avec un athlète de
haut niveau aveugle et donc c'est
extraordinaire on arrive à des prix les
résultats extraordinaires
et donc il est également de permettre à
des des femmes d'accéder à
certaines activités qui ne sont
pratiqués que par des hommes également
par exemple créer une équipe de rugby
par exemple eh bien il faut mutualiser
il faut mutualiser les shows du
territoire les différentes communes pour
permettre la constitution d'une équipe
de rugby de valeur si vous prenez chaque
commune il est possible si vous voulez
pas suffisant d'avoir un effectif
possible pour constituer de deux villes
villages contre lequel il faut lutter
justement pour essayer de regrouper les
nous sommes dans une situation il ya les
deux poules nous avons les sept communes
historique et puis les cinq communes
entre en entrée et huilé janvier 2016
et puis 50 ans line et cinq minutes et
il faut il faut il faut fédérer toutes
ces communes donc c'est donc c'est pas
si facile que ça mais il ya une volonté
une volonté des communes et une volonté
du territoire d'arriver à une
mutualisation et puis d'arriver à une
fédération de toutes ces associations
pour permettre d'avoir un des objectifs
communs et nous favorisons également le
sport de haut niveau
les jeux olympiques maintenant
effectivement donne une raison encore
supplémentaires pour favoriser motiver
nos générations de jeunes pour arriver à
des niveaux importants du kremlin
justement on parlait de toutes ces
associations qui existent les jo vont
être un outil de cohésion sociale
également parce que les jeunes vont se
motiver pour pratiquer des sports il va
y avoir la population qui va aussi
vouloir visiter les sites olympiques
les fûts sur les futurs sites la fiq
donc c'est de la cohésion sociale
les gens vont
mieux se parler il va y avoir de la
convivialité les gens vont converger les
uns vers les autres grâce à ce grâce à
cet événement
et puis effectivement retombées
économiques avant parce que si on fait
visiter les sites olympiques ça sera pas
forcément gratuit
voilà et donc c'est aussi le tourisme
avant qui va avoir de nouvelles
retombées économiques parce que quand je
reprends toujours cet exemple est parce
qu il est flagrant
le stade de france avant d'accueillir la
coupe du monde il était c'était un lieu
de visite
donc c'était devenu un site touristique
à part entière donc c'est ce qui va se
passer on va venir visiter le vélodrome
on va venir visiter tous les sites des
futurs sites olympiques et ça crée un
nouveau produit touristique et donc une
nouvelle consommation sur le territoire
avec des nouvelles pas tomber avant jeu
suivant le vélodrome
on voit bien que ça marche bien sur le
plan sportif ça marche un peu moins bien
sur le plan des spectacles c'est un
vélodrome
donc il y à rien mais c'est très
compliqué c'est assez compliqué
d'adapter effectivement à vélo de route
pour un spectacle du chanteur par
exemple ou pour un spectacle de faire
venir des gens puissent dire parce qu'il
ya effectivement un espace entre le
spectateur et puis le spectacle
véritablement au chanteur c'est un don
qu'il ya des problèmes d'adaptation
effectivement mais quand on voit que le
stade de france n'est pas rentable on
comprend on entendra peut pas chercher
toujours
vous essayez aussi de diminuer la portée
négative et le changement
voilà alors parlé d peut-être des jeunes
sportifs que c'est josé knopik vont
attirer enfin ou des associations etc
est ce que dans le golfe par exemple
c'est vrai vous fait beaucoup pour
attirer des gens notamment du territoire
notamment déjà de défavoriser vers ce
sport qui était pas forcément considérée
qui parfois considéré comme un sport de
riches ou de l'état est-ce que ça
sachant justement l'image est ce que ce
que les disquettes des nouveaux golfeurs
des gens qui viennent revenir sur le
mourre riches
non mais je sais que j'ai dit l'image
c'est vrai mais j'ai fait ce qu'on casse
cet humoriste images et des fausses oui
ça fait mais elle existe j'existe existe
on souffre evènement le monde d'une
période des années 70 80 où il ya une
explosion de golf mais c'étaient des
gaules cher parce que en malheureusement
on peut pas ouvrir un golf comme un
terrain de foot c'est à dire il faut
tendre le gazon il faut des machines
il faut des hommes il faut il ya un
entretien minimum à voir donc il ya un
doute
par contre une année de golf aujourd'hui
c'est moins cher qu'une semaine de ski
une année de golf c'est moins cher
qu'une semaine de ski et il ya des
formules pour les néophytes débutant au
golf national et dans les autres cols de
saint quentin en yvelines avec notamment
base de loisirs des formules de 10,80
euros par mois où on a le matériel
compris et on joue autant qu'on veut
donc là on peut pas dire on est moins
cher que des mots bobonne salle de sport
de gym
donc on peu fréquentés on est moins cher
que ça donc on ne peut plus dire que le
golf et cheikh sarr est plus sûr que le
foot ça reste plus cher que le foot mais
ce qui aussi de ses comités d g
je pense que les gens qui le rend si
vous regardez les gens partent au ski
c'est plus les noms et le vélo quand tu
vois des gens qui achètent des vélos à
l'effet de surprise jeudi je peux faire
trois ans de de gaulle après après on
viendra t'il son vélo non mais je suis
en train de dire que j'ai sans-faute is
et pour moins de 2 1 euros pass est vrai
que vous avez dit les efforts faits mais
est ce que est ce que ça attire une
nouvelle population et est ce que des
événements pour ça la rédac cup
je pense évidemment aux jeux olympiques
attire alors jeux olympiques c'est un
peu frais encore mais attire de 2,2 un
nouveau public
il y à du développement dans le golfe
c'est clair pourquoi parce que d'en
reparler du golfe mais ça pourrait être
dans les autres sports wii ce que cela
veut dire donc très fort il ya comment
dire des gens qui arrêtent le sport wii
qui arrive en fin de carrière sportive
qui ne peuvent plus de ce qui est bon
avec le golf et intergénérationnelle
donc de 8 à 88 ans on peut jouer au golf
donc un grand parent on peut jouer avec
ses petits enfants tandis qu'août à nice
est plus difficile ou plus compliqué
dans différents sports comme ça donc
c'est un beau sport déjà pour beaucoup
de personnes
maintenant qu'on aille chercher des
nouveaux golfeurs c'est normal pourquoi
parce que la fin de vie existent les
gens disparaissent les genres des
manèges
ils sont mutés y partent je crois qu'un
objet tout un panel de 25
enfin quand les gens arrivent à l'heure
commencé à travailler à une famille etc
les 35 ans de la baignade pour nous
c'est à ces commandes hier en est très
fort pour moins de 30 des nouveaux
golfeurs mais c'est et sentir plus de 50
ans et les plus de 50 ans parce que on
l'a peu de temps deux mais aussi de
revenus disponibles et on a payé
certaines choses de la vie l'éducation
de ses enfants par exemple
et donc oui c'est le créneau 30 50 qui
nous manquent mais on s'adapte parce
qu'on est obligé on est dans un monde en
mouvement donc ancré des produits
prennent désormais profiter pour ce
créneau là bon excusez moi le moi ce que
je pense c'est que l'image du golfe
cheikh vient aussi des golfs privé parce
qu'il ya deux types de golf il ya surya
les golf privé et les golfs comme le
golf national qui n'ont pas du tout la
même image le golf privé comme c'est un
nom la bretèche par exemple où il y
avait le trophée lancôme à une époque
tous ses golfs là ils ont une image
extrêmement haut de gamme et qui a été
qui a dont été assimilés l'ensemble des
golfs sauf que c'est pas le cas c est de
cette ça vous a été servi mais il ya un
changement parce que tous ces golfs là
qui étaient fermés parce qu'il y avait
beaucoup de membres à un moment et c'est
elle qui rêvait tout à fait vous arrange
oui mais dans l'esprit des gens c'est
resté comme ce soir ça fait aussi un peu
rêver c'est vrai qu'on a faim toujours
envie d'être dans un endroit où il y
aura quatre cent cinquante mille
personnes
mais si on peut se retrouver à faire du
tort zénon santos ne visible quand on
est dans le métro c'est bien ça ne va
juste avoir un magasin de chaussures
avec du 42 et du noir temps et c'est
exactement comme dans l'aviation ou dans
l'hôtellerie si vous voulez voyager
business class vous voyez business pas
si vous voulez vous low cost dans le
même style de la viande je veux dire
c'est un a320 il est tout neuf etc
mais le prix est du simple ou bien via
23 10 il faut qu'il y ait une gamme
d'offres adaptées et ça c'est le golf
aujourd'hui il ya une gamme d'offres
adaptées à ce que vous avez comme moyens
financiers et donc vous pouvez
comme vous pouvez prendre l'avion
aujourd'hui pas cher ou très cher ça
existe et de exister dans l'hôtellerie
vous avez sofitel où vous avez formule
un danger un groupe qui existe je veux
dire c'est c'est comme ça le golf
aujourd'hui vous pouvez jouer sauf que
sauf peut-être que les choses sont un
peu moins bien mais là vous pouvez jouer
sur des parcours qui sont aussi book les
autres fois parfois il ya des golfs qui
sont mal positionné dans cette gamme
ouais je voudrais rajouter pour le golf
et nous avons aussi au sein du
territoire
tout un programme initié d'initiation au
golf pour les jeunes
les collégiens et également pour les
écoles primaires et il y à il ya les
programmes croco golfe qui permet aussi
à des enfants défavorisés à pratiquer le
golf et nous participons le territoire
la fédération et la fondation lacoste
l'installation d'un poste qui permet au
secours populaire à la croix rouge à la
fondation méquignon également qui ont
des enfants défavorisés ou qui ont des
handicaps de permettre une initiation au
golf et il y a même au sein de sept de
ses enfants sélectionnés une sélection
une deuxième sélection pour permettre à
certains qui auraient des
prédispositions à rentrer dans un groupe
pour une initiation un peu plus poussée
et c'est c'est une participation qui est
très agréable pour le pour le territoire
et pour la fédération je pense je
voulais être signalé tout à fait rire
alors on sait pas s'il y aura des
français à la ryder cup sait pas encore
mais mais il y aura une équipe française
aux jeux olympiques oui grâce à cette
saison le sas où commence dans sa joie
en individuel alors le formule de jeu
pour les jeux olympiques je pense n'est
pas figé encore jusqu'à présent c'était
arrivé de rio le lien entre enel du
golfe dans les jeux olympiques qu'ils
ont fait un tournoi classique de quatre
jours
donc pour les messieurs et les dames la
semaine d'après il y avait deux joueurs
par pays déjà qualifiés donc y aura il y
aura forcément des des français en 2024
un mot encore des cocons ça se porte le
tourisme aujourd'hui il ya eu lieu toute
cette vague d attentats du terrorisme
qui a fait que qu'un certain nombre de
deux ressortissants étrangers ne
venaient plus on à paris a repris
semble-t-il dans les yvelines où on a
des parts dans versailles par exemple de
faire les sites les plus les plus connus
on a une développement nouveau de la
croissance des sites touristiques
versailles l'année dernière avait eu une
baisse de fréquentation énorme le la
fréquentation remonte et c'est un petit
peu partout sur le territoire comme ça
enfin dans la région globalement c'est
comme ça on a une
développement nouveau et maintenant il
faut pas qu'ils aient des grosses
attentats qui se reproduisent que j'ai
toujours comme ça et les jo vont
certainement avec le coup de projecteur
qui à ce que la richesse est un coup de
projecteur formidable alors cette région
et qui attira peut-être avant peut-être
après cependant il ya toujours le même
nombre peut pas toujours compter sur un
peu avant ou peu après enfin peu avant
comme pour la ryder cup il ya des gens
qui viennent tester le parcours avant et
puis on s'en doute des gens après aussi
enfin ça c'est évident c'est quand on
parle des jo on compense à l'hôtel rym
emilie a aussi toute cette nouvelle
gamme de produits d'hébergement
oui qui exemple les chambres d'hôtes et
la fameuse marque
airbnb 1 qui se développe énormément et
ça effectivement ça va se développer à
tout moment à la ryder cup aussi
d'ailleurs puisque on a fait le calcul
dans les yvelines pour la ryder cup
on n'a pas suffisamment d'hébergement
par pour attirer tous les visiteurs et
donc ils vont se délocaliser sur
d'autres départements donc sur les
hauts-de-seine sur paris et les
retombées attendues pourraient être plus
élevé si on avait plus d'hébergement
donc beaucoup vont aller dans l'herbier
m'bissa c'est clair et puis beaucoup
vont se créer surtout de nouveaux airbnb
ces nouveaux types de produits là où
d'autres d'autres sites phares mi mai
c'est celui qui fonctionne le mieux en
terme de chambres d'hôtes sont assez
curieux voilà exactement ça leur enlève
une clientèle ça c'est évident mais à la
rigueur ça ça permet d'accueillir une
nouvelle clientèle aussi qui ne serait
jamais venu et ben voilà on a encore
cette temps pour bosser s'est lamenté
recommence dimension culturelle aux jeux
olympiques peut-être retrouver des
preuves intellectuelle on parle beaucoup
de sport ce que programmé un petit peu
de nourriture intellectuelle
preuve une épreuve architecture de
france est interne pourrait refaire ça
avec coubertin ce sont les jeux modernes
que nous pratiquons actuelle c'est le
mot d'ordre très bien un petit peu de
c'était mieux avant c'est donc merci
beaucoup pour l'armée test je signale
que vous allez vous préparez vous allez
faire sur cette chaîne une émission en
anglais avec des avec des avec des
anglais comme vous qui vivent d orgue et
américains des australiens qui vivent
sur ce territoire on attend ça avec
impatience
merci beaucoup dans charlevoix dit je
rappel du passé faisons table rase de
malik gagne à magna voilà merci à tous
[Musique]